[Music]
the following is a presentation
of the saint louis chess club
[Music]
wow thank you so much for the subs there
and thank you to the saint louis
archbishops for playing the best
chess of the weekend and ultimately
winning the protesting championship
helping to bring
the title back to the chess capital of
the world
a world championship right back in st
louis where it belongs
your 2019 protest league champions
we're going to give them their medals
let's give them one more round of
applause here
[Music]
good morning welcome to the 2020 pro
chess league final four
my name is international arbiter michael
jake comer
manager of the st louis archbishops
today
at 9 45 a.m we will be facing the china
pandas our lineup today is definitely
the a-team
fabiano carriona the second highest
rated player in the world
and guess what magnus is not competing
in this event
so that bodes well for us board two is
the revered
lanier dominguez ford three get this
ford three is 2020 mvp of the pro
chess league wesley so board 4 is super
gm
jeffrey zhong who had quite a battle
with magnus
at the clutch chest event what are we
playing for
the winning team of the final four will
learn 20 000
gold medals and of course bragging
rights for
life the st louis archbishops has
accumulated
much hardware and accolades in the pro
chess league
in the first season 2017 we were the
world
champions in 2018's the finals were
played in san francisco
and we took home the bronze in 2019 we
went right
back there to san fran with a whole new
starting squad
the young guns and won gold again
also in 2019 the archbishops won the fun
new
summer series event we just win we
win so let's take a look at the format
we are playing the china pandas in the
semi-final
if we win we'll advance to the
championship on sunday morning
versus either armenia or canada so it's
four players per team and
all play all meaning our board one
fabiano
will play china's board one board two
board three and board four
so each player plays four games total
equaling 16 games
for the match we'll need eight and a
half to clinch the match and advance
in case of a tie it goes to the gauntlet
with faster time controls
and elimination style but the time
control for each game
is game 10 plus two second increment i
mean every time a player makes a move
receives a bonus two seconds the
archbishops are favored in 11 of the
games today
and great news if it's close we are the
favorites in
all four games in the final round so it
should be a doozy
here's grand master dennis burr with a
call
welcome to the party pal
thanks mike hello everyone thank you
for having me for this wonderful
occasion
of their resume resuming protest league
originally this was supposed to be in
norway
in may however due to the pandemic
it turned out not to happen but it's mac
and it's online and this time
st louis archbishops is going to face
none other than the chinese
pandas so let's take a look at their
results
the stateless archbishops actually have
a perfect score with eight
zero just demolishing the field
and actually just playing eight rounds
while the pandas actually played an
extra round
and as you can see it was fair routing
an easy one so we can see the players
originally la cuangliam and alejandra
ramirez mhm
benjamin buck and of course version
okobian was
part of the team but only four can join
for the finals
and they chosen mr mike comer chose
wesley so fabiano caruana dominguez
and chad um and
fabi did i miss someone i might have
i don't know so it's fabi dominguez
wesley so and jeffrey zhang so let's
take a look at
the pandas they actually had a much more
arduous rode to the finals they actually
scored
six three three losses which is
surprising
as they're formidable and solid players
headlined by dengleran vanguar
actually not as tricky as a
player feel that they have that they had
previously they had
young female prodigies play for them but
this time they went
all in for a traditional lineup
so let's take a look at the pairings
between the two teams
so lee chao is going to play fabiano
caruana
veyi lanier dominguez actually that's
something that i'm eagerly awaiting
as way ye is more of the
fire of chess and linear is the cold
calculating but
very solid play that is kind of staple
lenny bestly so you young yi
actually that's also a big rivalry
although i expect wesley to do
really well this whole event as he just
won the blitz championship in the st
louis tournament
tying with none other than magnus
carlson
jeffrey zhang versus dingle iran that's
going to be a difficult
battle possibly the only board where i
feel
that the st louis team is
outnumbered my rating points dingleran
has 2791 and jeffrey jean
2709 but jeffrey
has desire to outdo
all the chinese players and
all in all i feel that even though this
will be a close match
this should be easily won by
the archbishops
so let's take a look at the
format if you can
yep general format so teams are playing
from
four continents uh this is going to be
an online event
even though originally they wanted to
hold it in norway
they were forced to bring it back online
24 teams will compete in the 2020 pcl
season along with seven of the top 10
players in the world you can see most of
them
in this round but people like dingle
iran
juan cao and vanguard
and of course the whole st archbishop
squad time control is 10
to 2 seconds increment and head-to-head
matches
10 points for winning a match and one
for each game
one the final four teams will compete in
a live
final and that's the thing that has been
cancelled
so they're not going to have that
they're going to have it online
however in case of a tie this will be a
different format from the usual things
that you've seen
it's going to be a ladder format so
board four is going to play boar four
and from then on up they're going to go
up where there the loser of that game is
replaced by board three of the team
so if board four wins it's going to
face board three then two then one
and as long as the whole team is
eliminated
then that team is out so both
layers are element on a draw but the
only exception that if the match between
both teams first board
is drawn they continue to play with
colors reversed
until they finally have a winner so the
first game will start with opposite
colors
from the match and the colors will
reverse each game
the time control is three minutes start
time with
a one second increment
let's see if we have some games up let
me refresh
so how do we follow the players you can
actually
use the follow oh
let me find it right there
can't i go there right here you can hit
follow
and just choose the player
you want to follow i'll give you just
one example
so daniel dubov if you want to follow
daniel dubov
you just hit follow so slash follow
duels
that's daniel dubov hit enter
and you are following if you want to
unfollow and
you don't want to be bothered by that
anymore you just hit
unfollow and hit the same name
and now you no longer follow that game
and it won't pop
up but if you hit the follow it actually
works out
anytime wesley jeffrey corona or
dominguez
will have a game on and you are still
following it'll pop
up immediately on the side
so it would pop up on the side of the
board
let's say if you have two games on the
side
that would pop up but okay let me step
on back i can do it again
follow
and it is obviously on chess.com you
can't
follow duboff he's not online possibly
but you can definitely follow
let me go back
let's see
let's see if we have games we have no
games yet
three and a half minutes left to those
games
let's see so
here's the regular season standings
so the sailors archbishops dominated
the western division and as you can see
the chinese
team has barely made it in their own
group
that's kind of not surprising with a six
three
score six being the wins and three for
the losses
and just on a personal note
i myself has played for
quite a few teams part of them was
chicago when i did not play in
this season but it is somewhat
heartbreaking for me to see
chicago win just barely not making it
to the top four finishers in the western
division
just being edged out by the new york
marshals
now the eastern division was a tough
fight
but we have players so we see dominguez
the only player we're missing is jeffrey
and the up left corner
but they all seem to be ready and as far
as i know
corona is straight from
germany playing this match for the
archbishops
sipping is that an orange juice
apple juice looked very fruity to me
he's savoring it probably he's going to
savor this moment
for a long time
and just notice noticing it all of our
players are
be speckled i wonder if jeffrey will
also rock
a black class as well
probably so okay
we're looking at wesley's camera
so not no cad cam yet
we see the mic a pen but
sadly no cat yet but hopefully
if my intel is correct we might see a
chess-loving cat show up
and that would that would be great news
but until then we're going to be
waiting for the round to start
is jeffrey in the camera
yet
so we've got uh quick substitutes
is taking substitution he's substituting
jeffrey possibly giving a pep talk to
the whole team
and as i can see caruana is intently
listening
no no he's getting distracted
takes another sip
so all of the players seem to be well
adjusted and ready and as you can see
we are going to have a match between the
archbishops versus the pandas
on the other side of the bracket the
chess bras
are facing their armenian eagles
with canada chess bras kind of being the
favorites
but you never can underestimate the
armenian team
as they have what really matters and
that is
team spirit now if
the archbishops win today then you're
going to see
the team play on sunday in the finals
and if they happen to lose
to the pandas which will hopefully not
happen
they'll play a third place match on
saturday on september the 26th
and in both cases it'll be broadcast
here
in the singles chess clubs studio
so whichever match they will play the
finals
or the third place match make sure to
tune in for that one
as well
we've got lot on the line here because
20k
for first place 10k for second
third is 6k and fourth place is
4k so a win
is actually quite a leap forward
10k or 20k is not like 6k
so possibly we're going to see
a grueling struggle in these
orders i mean these matches because
the prices are just much much higher for
second and of course first place
so let's see what we have
no big matchups just a casual
match over here
between a czech grand master and the
brazilian one
is troubleshooting so i hear
that they're troubleshooting some
connection issues
and possibly after that will be fixed
then the games will start
so while we're waiting let's take a
quick peek at this game
so even though byte has the bishop pair
which is of a positive
it's a closed position and oftentimes
this could face knight g3 ideas hitting
both that rook and that bishop
so even though white is somewhat more
organized
black has very many good options either
knight g3 or knight f4 is an idea
rook g3 is somewhat surprising
or g3 probably if it captures you take
with the knight
and put pressure on that bishop you
could even consider taking with the pawn
with the hopes of actually getting a
knight on f4 bishop f1
looks a tad bit passive
i guess bishop e7 makes sense just
defending the pawn
sort of preparing ideas such as bishop
g5 because
as long as this bishop is gone
black will be able to plant a knight on
f4 and press
on this h3 guy bishop f2
and knowing the style of these players
knight f4 or d5 d5 interesting
d5 is an aggressive move and i don't
quite like it because it opens
up this bishop obviously
soupy's idea is to sacrifice the
exchange
and then roam on and on the dark squares
but the grandmaster doesn't really budge
and says i do not care and if you don't
want to take it well i
exchange off your bishop on f2
takes b takes
and black is clearly better has firm
control of the center
good center control this f4 square
is just going to get occupied there's
some pressure on h3
oh actually rook wasn't quite hanging
because of this bishop b5 check and rook
takes g1
so always some tactics to keep in mind
king e7 bringing in some
more pieces rook b8
rook h2 and you can see the piece
domination
actually works in black's favor and
a position can't really be that good if
you're going back and forth with your
rook
and now black is in cruise control
although down to 24 seconds versus
35 rook takes f3 and this is that loss
for white
with these pieces being crippled and
just can't move rook
f2 and after the b2 pawn is falling
it's game over however it's 20 seconds
for supie versus 24
so if the czech grandmaster
somehow survives long enough he might be
able to
play for the good old flageroo
key one check check
and probably it's time to capture does
not capture
rook d8 just putting pressure
13 to 10 seconds that's actually getting
quite steep
bishop g4 rook f4
h3 is very strong with this rook f3 idea
you can't capture
it's a taboo should be two
but five seconds left
for soupy that's not a whole bunch takes
check g7
[Music]
and
and black flags wow that's heartbreaking
so let's take a look
at lord dilidan versus michael royce
if you do not know lord dilidan is
actually richard rapport
so here he does have a very very strong
bishop
that is roy's putting pressure on the d4
pawn and with every dragon bishops
you get a good chance of holding bishop
takes d4 that always invites ideas of
pinning but in that case there's always
e5
king g7 and from a practical perspective
this is much more comfortable for
black queen c3 that's actually very
interesting
saying that this is going to be a strong
passer but i think
black is in due time just to block off
this pawn and then black has the
majority on this side
of the board
and round as i hear will start around in
10
seconds
so king c6 would make sense
or running with these pawns f5 e5
g5 i don't like g5 actually the more you
exchange the more likely you would hold
the draw
now this might actually become a runner
but they have infinite time to calculate
king c6
opposition very much important in the
end games
a3 king d6 and slowly but
surely black is singing seems to be
taking over
all right so we've got games so let's
start with corona facing
off here
vastly jeffrey
and this game so let's go back to this
game
rotate the board so
we are going to see the be hated opening
of the london
everybody hates the london for good
reason um bishop g3 was played
castles this is the main main line
now i wonder if fabi goes for b6 bishop
a6
the main issue in these positions is the
c8 bishop and
fabi does play b6 you could play bishop
a6 or play
a5 in both cases the same idea he
actually goes for bishop b7
that's actually very interesting
probably he's going for
the knight e4 knight f5 play
the whole plan is to kind of smother the
view of this bishop
just facing li ciao the ciao very
talented chinese grand master i think
they've played
b4 especially in norway so knight e4 is
played by fabi
the whole plan so either you go ahead
and exchange your bishop
with bishop a6 or you play
stonewall style play knight e4 and
f5 later
the only concern i would have if i play
f5
if white can't play knight e5 or not
so maybe corona can play knight d7
first and then prepare this pawn push
with f5
this is actually a valtried system i've
seen this being
played by hammer and
fishy anand as black
what are you thinking let's take a look
at wesley's game
wesley who's been doing really good in
the blitz section of the st louis
rapidan blitz let's see how he's doing
so it was a petrov
one of the tabias that they love to play
takes d4 d3 so he's actually not going
for the main line
b4 he's going for d3
g6 oh bishop b5 check
curious little idea ship g7
queen e2 there takes takes castles
so wesley seems to be in prime shape and
i can tell you why
he played bishop b5 check so if you
don't play bishop b5 check
this pawn is well guarded and there's no
weaknesses there but after c6 bishop d3
castles take six this d-pawn no longer
has protection
so yuyangi will have to waste time with
rook d8
king f8 bishop f4 and
black will always have to tend for that
big spot
so black can play d5 but in that case
there'll be many weaknesses on the dark
squares so one of the plans that
vastly could have in mind is something
like knight d2
knight c4 putting pressure
on the d6 square
however if you play knight d2 you do
have to
consider something like knight h5
so knight d2 knight h5
is something that you have to deal with
so wesley plays
h3 so in case of knight h5 he can always
talk that bishop away
knight d5 so the point could be bishop
h2 knight b4
trying to fork that's why wesley goes
bishop d2
a5 so yankee kind of plans to be
very aggressive in case of c4
hitting the bishop in that way so maybe
a3
is one of the ideas just preparing c4
and we sort of have an alakan sort of
structure
with a weak d6 pawn which i would think
is an advantage for white not a big one
but something durable as there's a
target on d6 and white has more pawns in
the center
let's take a look what's going on in
jeffrey's game
so start off this was a queen
c2 nimzo take stakes
the main line so
so far as i can see the tactic is
jeffrey is going to
neutralize or at least go for some solid
options
versus the chinese team while the other
players
are going at it ship f1 king f1
rugby one this is still main line the
king
looks awkward on f1 but after king e2
surprisingly it's very difficult to get
close to that king
the long-term idea of this whole line is
is to go for an end game and in that
case this king will be
very close to these weakened c5 and a7
pawns rook d5 rook c1
knight e5 take 6 b4
but with every exchange the likeliness
of a draw
rises in fact c takes
a takes queen b5 a draw is very much
on the cards however cb rook takes b4
could be something
that jeffrey is planning and in that
case there's no queen b5
check notice that this rook is sneakily
defending that b5 square
so actually c takes b4 does come
to mind
last but not least let's take a look at
this game between
dominguez and vayi and as expected
where he goes for the main line
dominguez chose
the berlin this is actually the berlin
main line which we haven't seen
so far that much because everybody
and their mother played d3 these days
okay h3 h6 now h6 is a rare line
usually everybody goes king e8
bishop e7 and h5 but
dominguez chooses h6 instead look d1
knight c3 knight e7 and this is the old
line played
in the famous world championship match
between
kasparov and kramnik played in london
now g6 a5 so white is going
for this a4 a5 move just to cramp
black making sure there are no b6 breaks
and there are no
fiance two ideas with b6 bishop b7 which
should be seven
should be three bishop d7 but as far as
i can see
lenny doesn't seem to be bothered knight
e4
trying to plant either a knight or a
bishop on c5
because bishop f5 trying to target the
c2 pawn
and hitting this knight here comes a big
question though
whether white can give up the pawn
or not actually knight g3 would make
sense
and in case of taking rook c1 and if you
move the bishop
let's say to b3 i can go a6
and try to break up your structure
it goes rook a4 just defend it laterally
b5 still doesn't seem to be working too
much you just take
and then you have a target on the a file
if i look at this this does look a
little bit better for white
with this king somewhat stranded in the
center
and with no real active play for black
so then he goes for this maneuvering
idea of knight f8
knight e6 trying to reorganize
sometimes you want to play rook d8 but
it doesn't really work now because
you could even consider taking on a7
so i'd say that the yi is putting a
little bit of a pressure
on dominguez i would even consider
something like
g4 just asking where that bishop is
going
if there is some exchanges on a4 then no
longer are there any threats
on c2 g4
bishop h7 then comes actually the
question how to continue
there and actually that's kind of the
difficult
part with the berlin
it's not that easy to come up with plans
knight f8
e6 is sort of an easy plan and then
maybe go a6 rook d8 later
but for white it's not as trivial to
come up with an idea
he does go g4 and i think that
the humble bishop h7 might be the best
and then just go knight to after that
it's still not clear for me that
i i don't know if white is having any
straight ideas
yet maybe rook d3 rook b3 could be an
idea
just go ahead and attack the b7 pawn
as you never have rook b8 i will have
the a7
pawn under attack so one of the things
that
bailly could go go and do is rook d3
rook b3
so maybe in this sense moving away the
bishop is not such a great idea
maybe bishop d7 is better
so in case of rook d3 knight e6 you have
something like bishop c8 it looks
awkward
but maybe it's tenable
but with bishop h7 i'm kind of worried
with ideas of rook d3 and rook b3 and
that could be an issue he goes knight e1
instead and goes for f4 and
f5 which is also quite annoying
so seeing that it would make sense to go
f6
just try to break it up and go for f5
breaks
and that's actually kind of the appeal
of the berlin
for the black players they want
to activate these bishops and if that
happens
white can actually run into trouble
himself
but let's take a look what's going on in
the game between
fabiano and li chao so
we did see we did let leave it off with
knight e4
castle knight d7 which is actually
avoiding the f5 stone wall play
a4 knight takes h takes c5
so fabiano is saying i will have the
bishop pair
and you don't really have any play for
it
queen b1 trying to put pressure on the
king side
with this battery g6
e4 cd cd
and you can see that fabiano with the
bishops is trying to open up the
position
interestingly enough he doesn't take on
e4 but plays bishop b4 instead
e5 hook c8 book d1
f5 which is sort of a strange decision i
think
f6 might have been a little bit more
interesting
maybe he was afraid of bishop h6 and
repetition there
so he went for f5 knight f1 mean e7
but all in all it's a comfortable
position with the bishop pair
like b8 just maneuvering the knight to a
better square
rook takes queen d1 knight c6 and this
knight is actually
getting re-routed towards the c4 square
rook c1 knight a5 knight e3 take stakes
bishop c6 whoops another target
queen c2 queen d8 and
we arrived at this position i would say
that black
is more or less comfortable there's a
target to play against
and what white is sort of lacking is
a target should be seven
now the question is what white can do
possibly some idea of knight d1 knight
d3
with b4 brakes could be on the cards
and that could be annoying b3
bishop d7 so sort of they're kind of
maneuvering around about
and it's not quite clear probably he
will want to play knight c6
actually a queen exchange would be great
for fabiano
maybe some of that queen f8 and go
knight b4
just exchange off that knight or even
bishop a4
and that's kind of the interesting
question he goes knight to b8
he's chasing the bishop away probably
preparing ideas such as queen c8
just go queen c8 exchange of the queens
and then just
hold comfortably
now black still has this bishop but
after bishop a6
black would get rid of it see goes
knight c6 i would have preferred bishop
a6
yes you're not would be a little bit
uncomfortable on a6
however i don't know about the
usefulness of that
bishop but knight d3 actually gives the
option of bishop a6
which i don't think fabi will miss he
goes knight a5 knight c1
now bishop g5 would force f4
because any knight move would mean that
this pawn on b3 is dropping
i guess fabi is saying that my position
is not worse at all
you have a weakness on b3 and maybe
if he could start pushing the g5 g4
h5 then he could even try to press
four more and as i heard and as we
anticipated
the jeffrey game has ended
in a draw but let's go back
to this featured game
h4 just exchanging of that pawn
i guess g3 is coming again so there
will be no bishop g5
bishop e7 king d2 so the problem in this
position
it is very hard to find a plan for
either side
it's defended and you have no ways of
exerting even more pressure
one of the ideas would be to get this
bishop off the board
oh king c3 that's a smart idea so
probably lee chao
is preparing to play b4 and then start
rolling
on the queen side bishop d7
sort of eyeing that knight d3
now you might consider b5 but the
problem is that would give away the c5
square
g5 g4 fixing the pawn
f4 well that can become
dangerous because if li chao can reroute
those knights to h3 and f3
the g5 pawn will be sort of weakened
probably that's the idea of knight e1
here anyways
he just wants to get that knight to h3
and f3
now black has oh king d8 i don't like
that move
because it actually goes to the wrong
side of the board
not f3 bishop e8
bishop d3 again not letting that bishop
out
and i'm kind of anticipating this plan
to actually materialize
and that doesn't look good maybe first
he should go b4 b5
just chasing this knight away yep b4 b5
and then going for this plan
this doesn't look good maybe a5
just in time before the ciao could
organize yes so if you play b5 i go
knight b4
exchange of that one pair of knights and
then you no longer have
enough pieces to target the b4 i mean
the g5 pawn
knight b for the question is if knight
e1 is
possible knight b8
avoiding that
okay this could be another plan
possibly fabi's preparing this idea of
knight d7 knight f8 and bishop g6
because if he manages to exchange this
bishop
he will be comfortably able to post an
iron h7
and the only weakness in his position
will be
exchanged off so as far as i can see
fabi is still wandering yep he's going
knight d7
king d2 and f8
bishop g6 is prepared
so this should be more or less
defensible
for fabiano he just needs to post the
king on g6 and it's a
dead draw
i wonder if he can go for a quick
exchange there
he avoids that bishop g6
captures captures knight f3
knight h8 knight f7 and the game is
going to be drawn
because there is no way of breaking
through
and the game did end in a draw so it's
one one
let's take a look what's going on in
this game
so we left it off
earlier around here
a3 b5 c4
and that minimal space advantage and
these pawn weaknesses
we're going to tell knight c3 knight c7
takes d5 you should be pushing in the
center
while you can knight c3
rookie 2 and this is a typical position
that
wesley really likes he has a little bit
of an advantage
on this on the queen side but
let's see if it's enough knight a4 rook
a8
knight b6 rook b5 and f6
for b7 check
so even though he has pressure
on the queen side it is not quite
clear yet as you young you can go ahead
and play king e6 g5 and f4
trying to gain some space there
but if black goes king e6 often times
you can switch
gears wesley and go rook g7
and try to win some pawns on the king
side instead
the only issue for white is in that case
that black could go rook c6 and try to
conjure up some play
on the queen side let's say rook g7
rook b6 check takes he's going for the
pawn
it's actually very logical and if he
manages to organize that
should be very close to winning but
again
here comes you yangi's counter play
g5 knight takes takes takes
f4 and the question is if yuyongi will
be able to sacrifice
the knight for these pawns on a3 and b2
and my hunch tells me that it is quite
likely to be the case
these pawns are way too advanced
king c4 and just stopping these pawns
knight c5
i would assume f4 is on the cards yes
gfgf
yangi has 17 seconds versus
wesley is one minute 45 but i think this
position is
fairly straightforward enough
e3 takes he's trying to keep as many
pawns as possible
um king e2
and in that case probably not h5 and you
would win that
pawn it goes knight d5 so just a
side note taking on b4 wouldn't
actually save the day because there is
still a g pawn for wesley
so let's see
knight d5 maneuvering the knight would
make sense knight e4
trying to win the pawn g4 knight d6 but
then king b3 king a3
and this knight is actually holding up
the b pawn
this looks very close to the draw so
let's see the other critical game
between dominguez and vayi
[Music]
an extra pawn for white but some
technical difficulties with both sides
having
very little time left also this knight
is actually controlling some important
squares
and it's not so easy to get close to the
f pawn
so even though dominguez is down a pawn
it's not quite clear he's going for king
g3 f4 that is vayi
but rook h6 is a very nice little move
stopping this f4 break and if f4 break
comes
you can just take and just go rook f
takes
rook takes f6 rook h3 and they
is going desperately down to six seconds
six seconds and
i'm looking at this position
soon enough we might run into some
threefolds that's why c4 was played
because he was worried himself rook h1
it's a strong move by vayi but the
question is
if there is a fortress or not so the
king will
walk all the way to the other side
actually no
he's going knight f8 there let's see
what's going on here
this ended in a draw as expected so
let's stick here
because this is the last critical game
that all games drawn
king e4 knight d7 bishop c3 knight takes
f6
and that is is that a draw i think so
that should be drawn
e4 at f6
and this should end up in a repetition
because there's just not enough
weaknesses
i'd be eight there's still some targets
there
but i don't know f6
and bishop e3 okay this is actually
getting
very annoying because now the king can't
come on in
ship d2 king f7 bishop c3
king e7 king f7 and so far
he's been holding
ship d2 can he go knight e5
and go for the f pawn not now because in
this case this bishop takes c5 bishop g3
knight f8 and suddenly the knight might
actually become
powerful
ship d6 knight e6 a very nice maneuver
by lenie king e4
and the king will shuffle around so i
don't think that black is in
danger anymore
there king e7 and here comes the big
question
whether it's time for the knee to get
more aggressive but i think
lenny knows that he should be just
patient and wait
for anything to happen i think vayi is
going to acquiesce to draw
in this scenario should be three and
we're just going to see
some king shuffling unless
he goes for b4 but it doesn't really
change the situation
because this knight on e6 controls
all these break in squares
king e4 bit more of shuffling
should b2
king g6 probably was setting up some
king f5 ideas
so that was stopped king f7
should be two
and i think it is a matter of time till
they agree to a draw
nothing really is happening we should
pay one a cheeky little move
avoiding the threefold but
it is still a complete draw
so a fairly solid round
fabiano made an easy draw
wesley was actually pushing versus
yuyongi so
that could have been a chance to take
the advantage and finally this game
ended a draw
and as predicted this will be a tough
match
with the chinese holding off
all four boards wesley so had some
chances to win
not that his position was completely
winning but
it looked very promising karana held a
slightly worse position
jeffrey's game was a very simple
draw although dominguez had to
struggle a little bit to get a draw in
the end
in fact let's take a bit of a look at
this game because we did
did not get the chance to look at it
we left it off around here
knight f8 g4 bishop h7
and there you played knight e1 but i
kind of assume you could go rook d3
and rook b3 and in most cases you would
be able to defend this guy on
b7 but not in this scenario
oop did i just
all right let me reload this game
i will refresh
did i manage to refresh it well okay
that game is gone sadly
um then we're going to take a look at
this one
between the chao and caruana
so it was a regular boring london
e6 e3 castle knight d2
b6 the best move but i definitely
understand this idea
you are trying to activate this terrible
bishop on c8
c3 bishop b7 ship d3
knight e4 castles knight takes
i mean knight d7 knight takes takes c5
and black can hardly be much worse than
the bishop pair
even though the position is rather
closed
queen b1 and i think it really has to do
with this being a team event
flubby might have considered playing f5
here getting
a good old stonewall structure
and have this maneuver of knight f6
knight e4
just centralizing you might even hammer
down the board with g5 g4
as a typical typical position and ideas
from the stonewall now b4 could be a
move here but in this case c4 is very
nice
ship c2 knight f6 and after knight e4
you go with g5 g4
and with this bishop still alive this
actually gives
some good play for black
but knowing that he goes
for g6 which again for some reason
doesn't show for me
so again i apologize i have to refresh
it
yeah uh so here knight e4
takes f f5
was an idea but g6 was played instead
but i think that has to do with this
being a team tournament he's not going
all out for a win
he's just being solid and also
the point of that is just to reduce the
scope of this bishop on d3
e4 cd cd
and to be honest with you i did not
understand why he
didn't take on e4 or something like e5
e5 is an interesting idea trying to open
it up for the bishops
there's nothing wrong with bishop b4 but
i just find it a bit more logical
to open up the position when you have
the bishop bear
anyways bishop b4 is still very much
solid
e5 rook c8 rook d1
f5 knight f1
and this position as you can see is
around even however
black will be a little bit worse
due to this bishop being passive on b7
queen e7 rook c1 knight b8
sort of planning this maneuver of knight
b8 knight c6 knight a5
also eyeing this idea of bishop a6
rook takes rook takes between d1 knight
c6
rook c1 knight a5 knight e3
why does the computer suddenly feel that
white is better
it is really due to the space advantage
that white has the space advantage is
quite big and that bishop on b7 is a
little bit awkward so
black does need to be a little bit
careful here
knight e3 take 6
bishop c6 in c6
bishop a6 and probably suggesting ideas
such as
g4 trying to blast it open
on the king side and probably something
that
white i mean black should have been kind
of
been avoiding or should have been
avoiding but with both sides kind of
playing it safe
and plays bishop a6 and g4 would have
been put
putting more pressure on but bishop a6
is a good
logical move bishop b7 b3
ship d7 queen c3 knight c6
knight c2 and b8
in c8 again just going for a solid game
but as you can see black has plenty of
moves and ways
of playing this position there's no need
for queen c8 but
can between it actually reduces the
tension take stakes
knight e1 knight c6 knight d3
and again this was the moment
i was illuminating during the game
bishop a6 is one of those ideas
that could work like with bishop a6
you could pressure on d3
and on e2 and with this bishop gone
with the board this would be an easy
quality
and after that it was quite simple
black closed off the position and even
though
the computer says it's a big advantage
for
white it's nothing substantial if you
can't win the g5 pawn
bishop g6 knight h8 knight f7
and the game was agreed to a draw
so now we're going to take a short
little
break and then we'll be back with
the games
[Music]
that was an amazing piece of calculation
that easily dominated these rivals
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the u.s and world chess
halls of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st
louis slough attracts students and
professors from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the saint
louis chess club to start
a top-tier collegiate chess team on the
very first year of the team's inception
slough obtained second best university
at the pan american intercollegiate
chess championships
higher purpose greater good st louis
university
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end
has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills
and increased confidence the chess club
is highly engaged with the local
community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the u.s and world chess
halls of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music
hello and welcome back so we already
have
the games started with fabi immediately
facing off with dwayi
and we have it moves in so we see
the good old e4 e5
advanced variation of the french so the
french
being the big craze these days which is
sort of surprising as
we actually talked about it in the
previous game when poppy was black
he was struggling with that bishop on c8
yet here vayi voluntarily gets that
bishop on c8
and enjoys it too so a3
um this is still the main line
b4 is the main move here and i would
assume that that's
what fabiano will do or bishop
e2 but that doesn't really make that
much sense
as far as i know b4 is the main line c
takes c takes or even c4
this is still a main line fabiano seems
to be
avoiding the main lines he usually plays
e4 e4 the d4 d5
knight c3 so more of fisher's style
this advanced variation is a rare guest
in modern practice actually now
older times i've seen bishop e3 played
bishop b2
is the other one bishop d2 is
the main main line but i've seen a
bishop e3 being played then
actually is quite venomous he goes for
the third option plays
bishop e2 now
black usually doesn't have too much
space
in the advanced variation however in
these side of
positions f6 makes a lot of sense
and black can hope for some counter play
that way bishop e2
you could go f6 or go knight e7
knight f5 hitting on d4
it usually leads to rather tense
positions something like knight e7
castles knight f5 you've got to defend
the d4
pawn with bishop b2
so knight e7 castles knight f5
it should be 2 and f6 and it's going to
be a mess
in the center that black trying to
undermine
fabiano's center and they yi
i mean they will be the one trying to
undermine the center
and corona is going to try to hold it
together
but let's take a look around the other
boards
as we're going to see ding lyran
facing off against the wesley
let's rotate this looks like a casual
and
normal english opening thing lyran's
favorite
bishop c5 is actually a fabiano line
first played by krishuk
then played by galfond and
later on played in the match between
cousin and karuana
castle's castles d3 the whole point is
you put pressure on that king and white
doesn't have the luxury of ever getting
a bishop on
e3 which would be possible with the
bishop on
with the bishop on e7 and not on c5
rookie 8 ship g5 just provoking some
weaknesses
take stakes f6 provocation
successful f6 is always a little bit of
a concession
you do create weaknesses along the
diagonal
on the g8 a2 diagonal
however it does bolster this e5 pawn
bishop c1 a peculiar choice
rerouting the bishop to b2
we should be six bishop b2 which should
be six at d4
so even though white has an extra
i mean white doesn't have an extra pawn
in the center but has
more support there
once wesley organizes he should be fine
bishop d5 is actually
eyeing against this bishop on g2
trying to make sure that that bishop
won't get
too powerful and also stopping e4
advances
if e4 d5 would have arrived on the board
that would have been a problem bishop
d5 another
silent threat of besties is to take on
f3
and gobble the pawn up on d4
and that's not necessarily the best
choice but it is
something that ding will have to deal
with
and that in mind i think e3 is a move
that thing could play but after
let's say
something like even knight a5 comes to
mind
just trying to put a knight on c4 and
play c6
black should be more or less okay here
so let's take a look around let's see
how lenient does against li ciao
so it was the asics line of the sicilian
not one of the main lines but of the
sidelines
favored by none other than morozevic
c4 knight c6 d4 take 6 e5
and this is sort of like a kalashnikov
mix with the o kelly where you do not
have that knight b5
idea as an option all right f5
so if you can't say a you might as well
see
b same idea you want to plant the knight
on d6
and if they don't allow you you might
re-route yourself to d5
d5 anyways cd take stakes knight d4
so black will get very active play
for the lack of the bishop
and even the white does have the bishop
pair
black is active currently knight c3
bishop g5
bishop takes takes bishop d3
g6 castles gf
now might has an extra pawn
probably could have taken on g6 but
didn't want to
activate black's pieces even a bit more
so castled instead king safety first
knight e2 take six queen d7
and we get this swashnikov type of
position
the question is how good is this for
black
queen f3 is a good spot by lenie because
this e4 fork even though looks
attractive
isn't quite that good because i would
just capture
f takes and this bishop is hanging
now f4 is a sign that something has gone
terribly wrong for black not only does
lenny have
a strong d5 passer there's no pawns
in front of it he has a much stronger
bishop on d3
than this guy on f6
castling isn't even possible because i
go
queen h5 and you get checkmated on h7
in fact let's stay with this game
because
this might be the first decisive
game of this whole match
bishop g7 i would even consider going
queen h5
yes you might be able to capture my
d-pawn
but that would come at a price of
opening up
this king's position
because this d-pawn even though is a
menace
it does block off the d file for white
so i think queen h5 makes a lot of sense
stopping you from castling because that
would be just checkmate
queen d5
rook d1 queen e6
and even after that you can swarm on in
dominguez decided to go rook d1 which is
a logical and very principled way of
playing
possibly after castles he would go d6
immediately because the pawn would be
taboo
any time you take on d6 there's bishop
h7
and suddenly you lose your queen but if
i can get
d6 in scot-free then rook c7 will be
on the line and i think
that would be more or less lost for
black
queen d6 lee chow noticing that that
would be decisive ghost queen d6
however this kind of allows queen g4
not only hitting this bishop but
allowing rook c8 to
check which does look
very annoying for black possibly bishop
f6
is the best move that you could do rook
c8 king e7
and pray that there is no decisive blow
in that position
bishop f6 and funnily enough you can do
the rivers
bobby fisher there and take on h7 so
bishop f6
bishop takes h7 you can't quite take my
bishop because i have queen g8 check
and i can decide whether i want to take
that rook on a8
or h7 so that's why
you remember all the classics out there
so you can use them
bishop takes h2 was a classic idea by
bobby
and here just the same you can do the
same move
bishop f6 bishop h7 just in a mirrored
position
with white in that case white would be
up upon
with a raging attack so i kind of
anticipate
this move to happen not that rook c8 is
necessarily a bad move but after king e7
i do not see the extra benefits
of playing rook c8
now one thing for sure is a good sign
for lee chao he has
an opposite colored bishop position
so if in the long run he manages
to survive this attack of laniers
then there's hope for him to survive
with the opposite colored bishop and
games rook c2
sort of again trying to double rook d8
and i still think bishop h7
is over there but it's kind of being
avoided by both sides
none of them seem to care probably they
were scared that there will be some
counter play
on the h file bishop e4 still a strong
move
just over defending the d5 pawn and
preparing the doubling
the hard part for here in this position
for black is that you don't really have
any play so you can go ahead play king
e7 rook d7
and just hold the fourth but that's
about
all you can do you are condemned to wait
so we'll come back to this one as we
look at the game
between jeffrey zhang and yu yang yi
so another position with the bishop pair
versus the two knights
we got a typical carpool variation
should be seven bishop f6 rook d1
knight e4 knight c6 um
even though black has the bishop pair
white has
more space and if light manages to
break through with d5 jeffrey might run
into some trouble
in this position i think yangi is either
considering bishop a6
or d5 bishop a6 also makes sense
because it would deprive jeffrey from
the bishop pair
and also would put some pressure on the
knight on c6
bishop a6 takes queen takes
you can't quite capture this d-pawn
because of
tactical tricks
in fact i feel that bishop a6 is more
annoying
than d5d5 i possibly can
capture bishop takes d5
even that i'm not sure he did go for
bishop a6 and i
think this is quite strong
jeffrey's under some heavy pressure in
this position
okay it takes queen takes
possibly the best scenario is to reroute
the knight to d5
and even though even in that case i
think white is better
it's not that it's not survivable so i
guess takes
takes knight to b4 and knight d5 just
putting that knight to d5 and chill
i would assume something like queen a4
will happen knight d5
and something on the lines of knight e5
trying to get an eye to c6
yeah queen a4 knight d5 knight e5
and white has an advantage
not a decisive one but something that is
difficult to play against
black is definitely having a position
that's defendable
but i do definitely would rather be
white than black
all right let's go back to the fobby
game
we left it off over here knight f5
bishop b2 bishop e7 so he went for a
quick castling instead
knight a5 a typical idea if ba
you can take on b2 so that will never
happen
knight d2 just stopping that
from intruding take six between c3
and here comes the blockading
castle's knight d2 you can never really
take this pawn
because you always run into this x-ray
trouble with b5 and you'd lose a piece
at least
ship f3 bishop c6 takes 6 b5
very nice little move by fabiano he is
cutting off the support and wants to
encircle the spawn
later a4 queen d5 rook d1
look at the 8 knight f3 h5
again stopping this g4 move which is
typical
in these french positions and maybe
hinting at something like g5 g4
trying to win the d4 pawn
suvaii has two minutes versus fabi's
341 bishop c1
actually stopping that and maybe
planning to play bishop g5 himself
as this h5 move did
sort of weaken the structure
a6 trying to undermine the position
i guess exchanging will happen
b-a-b-a and something like bishop
g5 is interesting however they might
actually lose a pawn
so you wouldn't want that
b6 is an option rook d7
a5 it just goes rook b1
i don't quite like rook b1 because it
sort of steps into tactical tricks
such as queen e4
and after queen e4 rook d7
suddenly there's lots of pieces
eyeing the d4 pawn queen e4 was played
queen e4 however it does run into
something like bishop g5 exchanging and
in this case the queen
will be under attack
bishop e3 just bolstering the center
so all in all as far as i can see
this round seems to be going the chinese
panda's way
so far that he has a little bit better
position
while dominguez
is better near winning
with the game between wesley soding
lyran
and jeffrey is still up and pending
i do feel that this doesn't look that
good
for the archbishops so far
a5 rook d8
a little bit of stuttering from vae
i did not quite get what he was doing so
it might actually be
a problem meanwhile the game between
wesley so and dingler and ended in a
drop
knight takes e3 f takes e3
and even though these pawns look
weakened it's kind of difficult to come
close with this bishop
at least would take lots of time to get
to h6
it will take one two three moves g6
bishop f8 bishop h6
to actually undermine that e3 pawn and
even then
fabi can just play king f2 and just
chill
and again that's why you shouldn't
really deal
dally that much you're actually
going to face some troubles on b7
and last but not least fabiano has
two minute 20 seconds versus vais 30
seconds
knight d2 chasing the queen away
however it does allow potential
bishop g5 ideas that might give some
play position is still very much
complicated
you wouldn't really be able to go e4
because bishop g5 knight f3
g3 and as i can see
dominguez did win his game so let's just
look what happened rook d8
we should be four king f8 rook c1 as
predicted
he doubled up on the c
file rook g8 queen h3
setting up some nasty little threats and
sometimes he would want to win that pawn
rook g7 rook c7 queen b4
queen f5 just getting and closing in
on the king g3 just creating
that space queen
b6 king g2 and suddenly
the rook might join from an unexpected
side of the board queen e6 that was very
nice
double attacking the rook and the queen
takes takes ship g5 takes
bishop takes takes and the first
win of the whole match as predicted
by lenie dominguez let's take a look
how's it going
in this game between yu yangi and
jeffrey zhang
this actually looks a little dangerous
we left it off around here
knight e5 but might having decent
slightly better position a6 g3
queen a7 a3 rook d8 but that's kind of
the thing with
these isolated pawn positions if you run
out of steam
with the side with an isolated pawn you
might as well find yourself in trouble
c5 they repeat once takes
f5 knight f6 check king g7 knight h5
and that's what yu yangi is doing he is
going for aggressive
play king gage seven but jeffrey has
seven seconds to
18.
so we're going to stay here for a bit
even though on
the other match karana versus
that he has no to zero time
left so in fact let's take a look at
that one
and suddenly yep
suddenly fabiano took over
and that's why time management matters a
lot
and this plan of playing bishop h6 and
g5
sort of backfired f5 between c2
rookie 7 king h1 between g6 queen f6
and fabiano is still chilling with 30
seconds versus
seven this position is very
uncomfortable
for vae rook c7 is a nice little touch
it's difficult to defend these positions
as you have no time and
corona is putting on a master class now
the b7 pawn is falling
the only thing left is to just
stop this attack probably taking his
best he goes for g
h takes but i don't like that too much
because it kind of gives some counter
play
knight g4 queen f5
maybe knight h2 not h2 obviously runs
into this idea so knight d5 obviously
h3 and that's kind of the reason i
wouldn't have wanted
to take on g4 because now black has
easy counter play on this side of the
board
and now we're going to have
a tricky tricky end game meanwhile
the jeffrey game ended in a draw a6
now this still should be winning but
it's much more difficult with seconds on
the clock
a7 check the king will be able to hide
uh and there's no more checks pawn is
promoting and that is
two wins with corona and dominguez
winning with wesley and
jeffrey drawing that is a solid lead
very good round for the archbishops
as we see corona leave
so a very good game um let's even
take a quick peek at this one between
jeffree zhang and yu yang yi
so knight f6 king g7 knight h5 king h7
and typical of yu yangi he
is always was known to be a fierce
competitor he never takes a draw he
might repeat
but he only draws if he must and
actually it was
kind of a good choice from him he had to
try
for a win that could have possibly ended
up
tying the match although it did not
as the game ended at a drop rook takes
rook takes queen e7
rookie one and even though
might has a v d4 pawn the king on h7
is a little bit iffy so jeffrey always
has
has to look out for some tactical tricks
or attacking ideas
and with jeffrey having much much lower
time
that you young he does it made sense to
continue
in g5 this is a typical and a very nice
classical plan
by jeffrey he brings the queen over to
g5 making sure
there is no funny business on the king's
side
h4 queen g4 then you
have a good old outpost and a weak d4
pawn for your opponent
you should go for the end game so queen
g4 is very nice
white is actually forced to take
otherwise this
pony on h5 would just fall
take 6 rook e4 king g6
now the knight exchange is forced h5
even f5 could be considered sort of
blocking that rook in but it doesn't
really matter
rook e4 king f1 check
king f6 and once the kings reach the
middle of the board
it is an even position and nothing
really happens here
the game was agreed to a draw
so an important game an important hold
by jeffrey
zhang and some important
wins for fabiano in fact i
am going to take a quick peek of how he
won
the game we left it off
over here around here
knight f3 and sometimes
being ambitious does backfire
instead of repeating which wouldn't be
such a terrible result in the position
black has some pressure on these pawns
and a potential passer
queen e4 would make sense but ambition
was a bit too much now he did go queen
g3
and even though this queen looks
formidable
rook c1 ship g5 between d2
it is sort of out of place
bishop h6 probably what vayi was
calculating that oh
for me to get this bishop to h6 would
take a lot of time but if i get my queen
to g3 first and then go bishop g5
that would be an easier route
rook b4 g5 and to be honest with you i
think
g5 is the move that is throwing it all
away
this bishop actually functions really
well there
puts pressure on e3 but g5
closes it all up and also kind of this
queen
is getting trapped and that h2 was a
splendid idea spawning that this queen
is uncomfortable on g3
also that knight f1 would just capture
that queen
so queen e5 knight g4 queen g7
rook c4 and you can see how the tide
turns
with three four inaccurate moves and g5
as a big blunder
already from a slightly better to
slightly worse to dead lost position
occurs if you make a pawn push that just
doesn't make
a whole lot of sense and after this
karana was cruising
in c2 king h1 just hiding from any
dangers
already with fabi having extra time
very just on seconds rook c7 was very
nice
slowly but surely pressuring on b7
ship g7 queen c5 takes takes
g4
takes i'm not a big fan i probably would
have considered taking on b7
because at the moment i do not see a way
for black to break through in any ways
and if f4 i will always have queen e4
checking and capturing on f4
but fabi thought otherwise that taking
is fine
f takes knight takes queen f5
h3 and the queen comes back in time
to defend the king and also note the
unfortunate placement of the king
you can't even set up these perpetual
ideas because i would block you with
queen h2
and it ends up in a draw
should be e5 d e
queen b1 check king h2 queen b4
a6 and usually these games are not that
easy to play but because of the
unfortunate placement of the king
this is completely winning between b7
engage 6 a2 check queen g2
and there is no more checks and again
i am just going to promote
so an important win by fabi
and lenier and that means
that the archbishops have
a lead a two win
lead versus the chinese pandas
so they will have to in the upcoming two
rounds
try to somehow
bridge the gap because in case of a tie
they're going to have a tie breaker in a
ladder format
meaning board 4 is going to face port 4
and if the board 4 keeps on winning can
actually eliminate
the whole team and they will do that
until the end until one team is
eliminated
so it's not all lost for the chinese
pandas
they have a chance to bridge the gap and
if they
tie it will go into a tiebreaker
but as far as i've seen as far as i can
tell
the archbishop team the st louis team
it's been
rocking so far so i'd expect
some coasting in the couple of rounds
although
i think the next round will be the
critical one
so we're going to go for a short break
and then we'll be
back with round three
[Music]
that was an amazing piece of calculation
easily dominating these
[Music]
as rivals as fears
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west
end has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the u.s chess championships
and the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to children throughout
the st
louis area research shows children who
play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame
this one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors
to experience chess in imaginative ways
and is home to the u.s and world chess
halls of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess
art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
welcome back for round three and
we have the pairings for
this round yes i heard
let's take a look and around that way
hopefully yeah
so we should have we should be having
around
in a couple of seconds
and here's the round three pairings
with yu yangi facing off with the white
versus fabiano corona
ding laran playing lenie dominguez
wesley versus ali chao and jeffrey
versus
vaiye
so this is a crucial round for the
chinese
pandas they will have to at least
bridge the gap at least win one
single game and win this round if they
do not win this
round the possibility of them winning
two games in the last round is
rather slim so if they want to catch up
they will have to do it shortly this
round
in round three definitely
definitely their last chance
if they think so if
they might probably their best strategy
would be to try to win one game at a
time at a round
and then tie the match but we shall see
what happens
it's not quite clear which is going to
happen no games yet
but i heard that
we are i heard that we are waiting
for one of the players to be
online and then the run will start
so so far has been looking good for the
saint louis archbishops
we have a 2-0 lead versus the chinese
pandas
so the pandas are on the back foot
they will have to be play much more
aggressive than they did
in the first couple of rounds where they
played solid lines
the london the petrov they will have to
fire up the engines and try something
more spicy
something with a bit more of a zest
not considering jalapeno sauce but
something
along those lines but as you've seen
corona and t the team is
ready to take on a challenge
now we are still waiting
and as far as i can see that
should be jeffrey zhang
taking a seat shortly
so the game is going to start
in 15 seconds so
it was a very important step for lenny
to win his game
because he did have some scares where it
says
vayi in the first round in the berlin
he was in the back foot and he had to
defend really well but he bounced back
with a very important win
versus um the chinese player
in the o'kelly variation where he
duly destroyed his opponent with an
opposite colored
attack so let's see
what we have here
yes we have games so talking about
lenny for a second
let's take a look at that game
so dominguez is actually
facing off dingler and this is a crucial
match
if lanier could stay solid that
would give a step
closer for the team to actually clinch
the match
h3 this is the good old juco piano
d5 and that is a very theoretical way of
playing
by lennier he does not mind an e5
weakness but he says
it will be counterbalanced by the pawn
on f2
question is how well prepared thing
lyran
is as far as i know knight d2 knight e4
is the concept that white is aiming for
in these type of structures
not only chasing this bishop away but
also setting up some knight g5
ideas bishop e6
it doesn't actually blunder upon in case
you take take
take you might recall bishop f2 king
takes
and queen f6 check winning the rook
on e5 so i wasn't really joking when i
said
that e5 pawn weakness is compensated by
that
f2 palm weakness c3
this is a little bit more circumspect
but after let's say queen d6
it should be more or less tenable
for black
alright so let's take a look at
fabiano's game
fabiano is actually facing off a
solid queen's gambit
with black it goes for a6
and c5 suddenly turns into
a slav and exchange slav
cbcb bishop f4 bishop d6
which means that he's going to have
again a quite bad bishop but that is the
only weakness he has
in the position e3 castles
knight d7 queen b3 rook c8
look c2 rook c1 and with accurate play
this should lead to nothing more than a
draw
one of the things that y can aim for in
these type of positions is to target the
b
and a pawns go a4 either prepare
something like queen a3 so you can have
a target on b6
or go a4 knight a2 and queen b4
and after the exchange of queens target
the a6 pawn
so some sort of a maneuver of knight a2
and knight b4
b5 trying to gain space
and in case of a4 you can already go b4
and a5
just closing off all the play for
white so it makes sense for you yangi to
just go a3
and then do whatever i said earlier
just in a smaller scale instead
of the a4 idea
however one of the things that yangi
will have to be very about
is a potential maneuver of knight b6
knight c4 which can become annoying
or a break with e5
often times you can accept the fact that
you'll get
an isolated pawn because
pine itself an isolated pawn does not
lose you the game
in any case the position is around even
let's take a look at what vastly is
about he is playing
a classical classical line
an open sicilian and as i told you the
chinese panda the china pandas
know that this is their last chance to
bounce back so li chao goes all in and
tries to play
the night or however wesley goes with
this rare
f3 move which is an interesting line
leading
for more these marotzi type of positions
which is
very much in wesley's style
takes bishop d3 takes takes
and there's lots of exchanges and even
though there's a pawn weakness on d5
white's king isn't the most safe
ship d6 h3 rookie 8 bishop d4
and bishop c5 is a move that i wouldn't
really say is the best li chao is
actually exchanging pieces when he
should be
keeping them on the board takes
queen f2 and after an exchange on f2
this will be a simple game where only
wesley can when draw being the other
result
possible so we already looked at
all three boards but we haven't looked
at the fourth
between jeffrey zhang and they yi
between the two youngsters at f6
so as far as i can see he is trying to
be solid plays
the semitarash that's been quite popular
these days
in the candidates and
in top events at f3 castles
still the main variation b5
bishop d3 queen c7 a4
and jeffrey is playing it more of a
positional style
he doesn't go all out which they usually
do
some people prefer going e5 and going
for direct attack against the king
which is definitely playable he goes for
something
more reserved b a i think there's some
ideas
connected with queen a2 and trying to
win the a pawn
and hoping to use the fact that black
has some weak pawns
on a6 and c5
actually a good choice by jeffrey
because
in this scenario again he will have
chances to push
with without really being in any danger
of
losing so queen a2 is one of the things
that i would consider
however as clumsy as it looks knight b6
might be an
issue defending the a4 pawn he goes d5
an interesting choice
so if take 6 that would really work in
geoffrey's favor
because in that case knight f6
if jeffrey manages to push the pawn to
c4
he is going to have a superior position
and i think e takes d5 wasn't the best
try by beiji
and after c4 this will definitely be
slightly more pleasant for jeffrey
sort of not f6 c4 and sooner or later
the a pawn like the a4 pawn is going to
fall
and after that white is just going to
enjoy a slight advantage
so again let's take a look at the other
games
this game between karuana
and yu yang yi as predicted
mass exchanges of the rocks now this
might surprise you it doesn't really
mean it's a draw
because there's still some targets on
the queen side
so fabiano still has to be careful
and if you've noticed in all four of
these games
they're trying to get a position where
they risk
little yet they have a chance to fight
for an advantage
and i think this type of play kind of
favors
the team of the archbishops as
any draw is just getting us closer
to victory queen d6
so fabiano played queen d6 just to stop
the screen from infiltrating
through the dark squares however that
kind of reminds me what if
white actually goes queen c3 or queen c2
setting up ideas of queen c5
not f4 that's sort of a strange idea i
don't quite get it maybe he's planning
to get the bishop away go knight d3 and
then
plant another knight on c5 targeting the
a6
pawn and the bishop on b7
however i think knight d7 will be an
option just to
get rid of the e5 knight
and you don't have f4 anymore because
your knight is in the way
so let's say knight d7 knight d7 knight
d7
and with every exchange i feel that
any sort of advantage that yangi has is
dissipating
let's take another look back in this
game we left it off
over here on queen f2 and again here you
see
that the moves are dictated by the
result
liecho plays d4 he needs to keep on
pieces on the board
otherwise they'll be just far too behind
knight e4 but wesley is not against
exchanging
also he has a clearer view on the d-pawn
rook b8 rook d1 rook d8 bishop takes h7
kaboom missing this nice little tactical
shot
of queen h4 queen d8
king f8 bishop e4 should b7
rook c1 and if
vastly wraps this up that would be a 3-0
lead which is nearly unsurmountable
b3 queen f6 bishop c4 slowly but
surely wesley is doing
the technical task once you're up upon
it's time for you to exchange
he could have also considered trying to
infiltrate on the seventh rank
and push that way but he just wants to
make sure that
everything's under control a5
that's a strange decision i do not see a
reason
why queen takes d4 isn't good
here
i did not pay attention but maybe it
wasn't just
me scratching my head might have been
westley as well
queen d4 and probably we had
exactly the same thoughts i do not
understand why black
gave up that d4 pawn maybe
just giving up on the game and with two
pawns up
this should be relatively simple for
wesley's caliber
to convert even if black would start
exchanging
at the end of the day i would have a
past
c-pawn promoted by my rook
and in that case it's just game over
not only do i have that passer i have a
majority on the king side
that three whoop three
versus two and that should be an easy
one
so that would mean that this will be
three zero
pretty soon
so let's take a look at this game
between jeffrey and vayi
so so far it's looking quite good for
the archbishops as they have quite a
nice position
in this game jeffrey has a better
position
putting pressure having a much better
structure and these pawns are just weak
while corona might be slightly bit worse
but not by a whole
bunch should be two
is there any active play that
jeffrey could look for i mean
that you could look for possibly
something like rook e8
queen c2 and knight e4
or maybe rook a8 and knight e4 and f5
that's the best shot that way he has
trying to muddy waters just give up the
a pawns
and hope for the attack
rookie 8 yep and then he knows that he
has to go
all in knight e4 f5
and this might actually be
much much worse than it looks
for white with most of the pieces being
on the queen side
94 94 knight h4
trying to stop f5 brakes
and also hitting that g6 bishop
even that looks uncomfortable
we'll come back to this game um
which one haven't we looked at we
haven't looked at this game
between lenier and dingleran
we left it off over here
at this position played bishop b6
bishop b3 rookie 8 so this knight e5
never
works as we talked about before because
of bishop
f2 king takes f2 knight e5 tricks
bishop c5 knight c4 f6 d4
and even though black managed to
stabilize the position
it came with the concession
of setting up some of these tricks ship
f8
bishop d2 d7 a6
knight d3 ship f7 bishop a4
and bishop b3
although as far as i can see lenny has
consolidated and that d-pawn looks more
weak than
strong and it's actually quite difficult
to get close
to lenny's king
if they take he will take with the queen
and with no direct pressure against the
c
pawn it is lenie who's calling the shots
and not being lyran
so that in mind so far this round looks
quite balanced
with the yi having some chances
to play for a win wesley is completely
winning
so and best case scenario for the pandas
it's
1-1 but that is still up in the air
and the jeffries game is still pending
but i do think that
wesley is going to notch that game
this game i feel that dominguez is doing
fine he's doing fine on the clock as
well
he has three minutes versus two let's
take a look at karana's game
so we left it off over here on knight f4
he did go knight c4 he didn't go knight
d7
queen c3 g6
h3 queen b8 b3
takes takes but isn't that a pawn
that looks like a free pawn and again
that was kind of the issue with this
knight f4 move
you never ever have that f4 move again
which is a problem a4 ba ba
knight e5 bishop f1 knight c4
although with this bishop still being
closed in
yu yangi might have some fighting
chances
but this does look quite good for karana
with
up an extra pawn only thing that i
would be a little bit concerned with is
the king on g8
because it is sort of lonesome
something like queen f6 can be
irritating
however in that case maybe you can go
queen e5
just chase the queen away
but that in mind it seems to me
that this round is definitely in the
archbishop's going archbishop's way if
fabiano was to win this game that
would just be the nail in the coffin
for the pandas
queen d6 and again i don't quite like
this knight
move to d3 probably trying to
consolidate
with f4 but i don't quite believe that
e5 seems to be a logical move followed
by f6
and once he consolidates the center fabi
should be
coasting
all right let's take a look at wesley's
game
leslie's up upon
nothing spectacular has happened it's
been
quite simple let's take a look what
happened earlier on because
let's see some fine technique from
wesley bishop c4
actually took on c4
b6 king h1 so wesley's not
going and taking chances he's up plenty
of pawns he needs
no risks queen c5
any rokan game would be winning so lee
chao obviously avoids it
f4 rookie one
basically offering queen exchanges
wherever he goes
and li ciao quietly denying all of them
d5 queen e5 book takes rook a5
basically trading off the b-pawn for the
a-pawn
and this is the moment it's starting to
get very critical
for lee chao once this rook
either goes to the other side and starts
bothering the king or you can start
pushing
that is actually a matter of style
wesley prefers the technical move of a5
instead of rook b4 rook g5 which
probably also works
and might have forced the black to be
very precise in defense
and force an exchange which would indeed
win the game
however a5 is thematic
and just make sure that everything is
defended
rook d8 so you can start pushing the
pawn up
and creating weaknesses
or maybe go rook c5 rook c7 trying to
take
a hold of that he goes rogue b6
saying i do not see your plan
tell me more about your ideas
okay
apologies
so back to the game we have
queen g3 being played
there and
wrong game queen g3 played
rook d5 and i do not like what wesley is
doing
he's actually trying to go for an attack
when he was mostly playing on the
queen side so even here with king 87 i
would have preferred some luggage for h5
and h6 and just provoke some weaknesses
queen g3 seems a little indecisive not
that he is not
still in a better position obviously he
is but it's just getting a bit more
complicated than it should be
maybe he can go check go queen b4 and
set up rook b8 ideas
yep queen h4 queen f4 same idea
just blocking off any checks and if you
would take then i have rook b8
and queen h4 or just queen f7
if queen takes i check and take on f7
but again rook takes a5 here king h7
where where is where is the idea
maybe queen e4 check trying to probe
yeah they're queen e4 because here king
g6 and you can't really
they're rook f8
f6 f6 i guess you can go queen e4 again
f5 and then queen e8
king g6 but that move just looks too
much
fun king f6
i do not understand what cha was doing
but probably he thinks this is the best
practical chance out here
between c6 g5
h4
just luring that king out in the open
it goes f4
after takes i can go check and look up
seven
and then leslie is just going to clinch
possibly the child is just going to
resign
after check and vocab 7.
yep book f7 one because queen f7 queen
f3 check
and you win the game very important when
by wesley and that actually
means that there's a big lead going on
ship d3 so far in this game faviano made
a draw
which is still beneficial for the team
so let's take a look at this one
which again turned in
jeffrey's favor he will always be able
to
give up this bishop but after this takes
this pawn you can never take
promote and that is probably the end of
it all
for the chinese team with
so many wins for the archbishops
this is near to guaranty and
jeffrey wins and this is a near
guarantee
that the archbishops are
through to the final let's take a look
what happened we've seen most all the
other games
okay
let me see refresh
so this was basically a clincher with
the archbishop's clinching the third
round
and with only one round left
that's unlikely that the
chinese pandas can actually make a
comeback
unless it's a heroic comeback and in
that case
they have a little hope
however it's pretty slim
so let's take a quick look at what we
missed
we missed it around g4 bishop g6
bishop b2 rookie 8 queen c2
and knight d7
or knight e4 both seem
legit knight e4 is a move that's good
rook e1 queen
b7 f5 doesn't really work because of gf
and there's pressure on this knight
so queen b7 was played knight h4
and here they goes for a tactical
sequence with knight takes f2
which is quite nice if you take with the
king
i can take on d3 queen d3 and this
bishop on b2 is hanging
so jeffrey went for something
different knight g6
knight d3 here there was a complicated
line
that was missed by vayi he should have
taken
on h3 king g2 and rookie one
and after that he has a very very strong
attack after f take g
but he decided up it
jumped on me
decided to go knight d3 instead knight
f8
rookie 1 rookie 1 knight e1
take stakes bishop g7 and
even though black is up a piece this
king is sort of
vulnerable and in big time trouble
jeffrey actually manages to turn the
tide around
he's seven queen e4 check queen takes e1
and even though black has this a pawn
the future
is looking bright for jeffrey as these h
pawns
h and g pawn can be quite dangerous if
it starts running
between b3 in f2 in b1 check
and e4 takes takes
and suddenly a position that look really
good for
vayi turns into a terrible one
because jeffrey is in time to stop the a
pawn from marching
takes bishop h8 you can't capture that
bishop
surprisingly d6 you will have to come
back
to capture this guy ship g7
ship f8 and with these pawns
blocked on a6 and c5 it's a matter of
technique
by jeffrey zhang g5 c5
c6 k4
and after the king walks all over to f3
it's game set
match and we'll be
back shortly with round four
of the match
[Music]
that was an amazing piece of calculation
easily dominating these rivals
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west
end has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess
and is comprised of two unique
non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments
including the us chess championships and
the sinkfield cup
one of the strongest chess tournaments
globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries
led by an expert commentary team of
grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess
with a specific focus on bringing the
benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows
children who play chess exhibit improved
analytical skills and increased
confidence
the chess club is highly engaged with
the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club
is the world chess hall of fame this
one-of-a-kind cultural institution
invites visitors to experience chess in
imaginative ways
and is home to the us and world chess
halls of faint
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions
and monthly music in the galleries the
world chess hall of fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries
and a premier gift shop highlight the
culture history
and creativity behind the game come
visit play chess
leave enriched to learn more about the
st louis chess campus
visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
we should move
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st
louis slough attracts students and
professors from around the globe
in 2015 slu parted with the saint louis
chess club to start
a top-tier collegiate chess team on the
very first year of the team's inception
slu obtained second best university at
the pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
[Music]
purpose greater good st louis university
[Music]
that was an amazing piece of calculation
easily dominating these rivals
[Music]
hello and welcome back for round four
of the protest league match between
the chinese pandas and the st louis
archbishops
who are leading with eight to four
that big wins in the previous round by
jeffrey zhang and sleazo
excuse me and that would mean
that the chinese pandas will have to
go for just to tie the match
but in case that miracle would happen
that would actually lead into a tie
break
between those four warriors and
the chinese pandas but as
far as i could see this doesn't look
like
the match for the chinese team and
as you might have noticed most of the
players are quite relaxed
so in the last round fabiano caruana is
going to face off with dengleran so
board number one
versus board number one for number two
versus number two
etc etc so linear is playing
you young yi veyi playing wesley
and lee chao is playing jeffrey zhang
on the last board with the
slight but substantial
actually substantial advantage of
ratings
should tell and that should favor the
arch bishops
and let us see what we have here
no cad cam yet sadly but hopefully
we will see one on sundays
have no confirmation yet but
if we get enough fan mails we might see
wesley's cat make a return
to the internet
you're getting ready for the round to
start
and if i recall correctly jeffrey was
fizz bumping at the end of his game
realizing that game was very crucial
and that might have been the one
ceiling that this game must be for zero
for the chinese team otherwise
they are eliminated meanwhile we're
waiting for this game
let's take a look at the other game
that's going to happen
today between the
armenian eagles
and the canadian
chess bras that's going to happen
in an hour after the match between the
saint louis archbishops and the china
chinese pandas so
if you want some more chess
action then feel free to tune
in for that one as well
and on chess.com and then you will be
able to see
who the singers archbishops is going to
face
next round either the canadian
team or the armenian one
so that's going to be
a very interesting match with chess bras
having likes of anish agiri
eric hansen the chess bra himself
and the whole armenian team
who's probably one of the most
well organized and as far as i know they
always
congregate in one space to play
their matches or they did before
in the pre-season
so you can see that chess bra is
facing the armenian eagles so
that's one uh number one
facing number two
and so the armenian eagles actually
had an easy routing versus the marshals
while the chess bras faced off with the
chicago
wind with the same exact result
now if you want a little bit of a
prediction i would say that
the chess bras are likely to be the
favorites
with higher ratings but
the armenians are an enthusiastic group
of people and i
wouldn't be surprised if there would be
an upset
brewing there so again if you
are hungry for more chess games after
this match do check it out
on chess.com that's going to happen in
an
hour and meanwhile we have our first
game
between jeffrey zhang and lee chao
and you can see just from the opening
that they're going for something off
beat
so li chao immediately chose
a rather solid line as
white keeping as many pieces on the
board
as we talked about it the chinese team
does need to score
4-0 to tie the match so
it is just logical for them to keep as
many pieces
on the board as possible
so this is actually a reversed philidor
in fact bishop c5 is kind of a nice move
however often it gets attacked so i'm
not 100 sure
if it's the best choice here but
obviously black hasn't committed any
chess since
to really speak of any right advantage
let's take another look on wesley's
board
wesley is facing the non-standard
larson variation and he wesley comes up
with queen e7 which is a rare line
usually you see the equally weird
looking bishop
d6 he went for queen e7 knight c3
a6 bishop c4
g6 would come to mind just to start
going over defending the e5 pawn
and then putting the king into safety
but again this
kind of shows that the pandas are
looking for a full-blown
fight on each and every board
going on to lenie dominguez
and yu yang yi we see
the good old petrov which actually
surprises me
yes it is not
a bad opening but going for a win with
the petrov
that is not likely to help the cause
and with this line that lenny plays he
gets a little bit of an advantage and a
little bit of a push
and this is quite looking good
for lennier
could even consider something like b3
bishop b2
might be a little bit off-beat and not
necessarily the more usual way of
playing but i would rather want to get
that bishop
to better position if i can or maybe
something like bishop b5
can be on the cards just to try to ruin
black structure and after that knight e5
exchanging some more pieces and putting
pressure
on you yankee but in any case this
has to be slightly better for many
dominguez he played c3
castles and i wonder if he's going to go
between c2 or capturing on g6
immediately
in any case let's take a final look
on the game between caruana and
dingliran
so here we see a good old
g3 fianchetto kings indian
kind of a rarity from fabiano as fabiano
usually plays
one e4 and not d4 systems
but you never really know that super
grand masters
they can play whatever whenever and
whatever they like castles a6
bishop g5 and this is some sort of a
sideline
i've seen rook e1 rook b1 b4
but this is actually kind of comfortable
as well ship f4 rook b8 rook c1
sort of x-raying the knight on c6 and
trying to put pressure that way
b5 takes takes d5
e5 counter attacking
d e bishop e6
and it's kind of strange
these positions are kind of strange
because there's a knight fleeting on c6
but for one reason or another it's kind
of difficult
to get close to it and oftentimes you
would have this knee-jerk reaction of
playing
a3 but in that case there would be b4
knight b5 is not a move that i like too
much
because black can take on b5 take on b2
and the a2 pawn is going to be
weakened
so that actually doesn't quite look that
great for
fabi if i can
tell but okay let's go back to
the jeffrey game how that is going
in c2 we basically have a reversed
philidor
d4 takes bishop g4 takes
and it's sort of going according to the
plans
of jeffrey at the end of the day
if jeffrey manages to
put a piece on on d4
he is just going to have a superior
position
not to talk about the fact that he can
also think about maneuvering the knight
to e6 and target that d4 square
that way
so so far looks quite comfortable
for jeffrey
knight d4 might be a little early though
because white just is in time to
exchange all those pieces
off rook d8 which doesn't really
threaten a whole bunch
because if you go ever go knight d4 i
take the a5
pawn a little bit more worried about
rugby one and b4 b5
that looks a little bit annoying but
again inside
2020 i can go knight g4 target the f2
pawn and any sort of repetition is in
favor
of black as we know the match results so
far
so this is looking good for jeffrey
zhang
not so much for caruana
what's going on in wesley's game
so we left it off over here with bishop
c4
g6 h4 h5
knight f3 bishop g7 knight g5 and this
is the typical mess
that probably they was hoping for
but as far as i can see it's not that
easy to
break through with g4 then i can always
capture
but said saying that it's not something
that is standard
so basically anything can happen in this
game
castles maybe 9 d5 would make sense
takes bishop takes d5
d6
and white has some fighting chances but
an advantage
i think that would be a bit too much
that bishop on b2 isn't as good as it
should be in the larsen
it's actually blocked by the knight it's
not that easy to make headways here
however i do think that something like
knight d5 and f3
g4 should be valee's plan
going for broke because it's really a
win that will count
in this scenario so let's move on
from here to lenier and see
what's going on in that game so we left
it off
over here with queen d2 bishop g6 and
instead of bishop b5
lenny chose the more circumspect move of
c3
castles queen c2 queen d7 bishop
f4
rookie 8 rookie 2 bishop f8 and might is
just going to do
the slow poke doubling on the e file and
having
that extra space and just enjoying
that minute advantage of owning the file
and to be honest with you this should be
rather holdable
for you young yi but
can you win it that is doubtful that is
doubtful
if you have any chance to turn this
around and
make this from a draw to a win not
impossible
but unlikely we need to again
controlling that square and i'm kind of
shocked not to see bishop takes d3
happen
i feel that yuyongi is trying
to be as defensive as possible
i guess takes nh3 makes sense
with black really not having any active
ideas
so let's go back as we went all around
to karana's game if he actually found
some ways to sort of neutralize
the play of dings
so we left it off here with rook takes
b2
queen c1 rook a2 rook takes c7
so he's actually trying to vacuum off
the pawns of the board
but that only means that
white might not be worse or lost
but there's no advantage in this
position g5 bishop e3
knight d5 rook c6 and my main
question is what happens if white
actually faces rook takes e2
rook e2 maybe bishop d2 trying to trap
that
rook
that's one of the ideas possible or
something like knight e3 queen e3 bishop
d5
and then go rookie 8 rookie 8 and
threaten rook takes e2
in both cases i kind of feel it's black
who's dominating a little bit
but it's not that easy because
the advantage is on one side of the
board
so if rook takes e2 i sort of think
bishop d2 and this rook is
kind of trapped
and i don't quite see
how black can untangle
also knight e3 queen takes bishop d5
can lead to an advantage so white is a
little bit behind
but not that the fight is over
black still has some work to do to
actually prove
his advantage
so let's see what's up with jeffrey's
game oh and some
fireworks in jeffrey's game let's head
on over there
he left it off over here couldn't really
go rogue b1 because of knight g4
played h3 and here comes the big knight
slaloming
knight e5 knight f4 takes boom on h3
and this is a big problem
because if you take i check you
i can't take the repetition and clinch
the match
or just check you until you have to go
back to h1
and a rook rover
to h6 via d6 is going to be decisive
so not only does jeffrey have
at least a draw he can even go for more
and why not
when you are winning knight f2 takes
takes
and queen h6 is deadly so black really
doesn't have any time to
take the exchange even because it's made
on
h5 check and mate on h5
ship g4 keeps on fighting like a good
team player but it really shouldn't help
that much
also jeffrey can just take on c6 and in
case of bishop g7
just play queen g6 attacking the bishop
on g4
and g7
this is basically the decisive game so
let's
stick to this one and see how
zhong clinches it
mine is sort of agonizing and what's
said enough
you can't really defend this guy either
if you go rook d1 i might be able just
to take on e4
anyways because if you capture i have
this long range move you've got to block
and that guy is not defended
rook d3 she's also winning
you can't quite capture the bishop this
one's hanging
if you go here i just go queen g6 and
everything's under control
and jeffrey is just up the exchange
ship f5 trying to set up some counter
threats
actually i'm starting to wonder if
there's some sacrifices but
the f2 is hanging so why leave that
there
so you could go bishop g3 just keeping
this
king smothered over there
yep bishop
excuse me
and there's some potential threats of
doubling anyways
bishop g3 rook the 8th is coming rook d1
so this is just completely winning
for jeffrey
you can try bishop h8 but i always have
queen h6 check
with a big advantage
rook the eighth just setting up this
rook d1 and
because of these squares being covered
black is going to face
some issues
d1 that's a background mate that is hard
to deal with
you still have to do something with your
bishop
if you move it away then you'll face
rook d1 and your queen is overworked
you can't defend the f1 rook and the
bishop on f6
in that case it leads to a loss
queen a1 trying to juggle two things at
a time which never ends
in any way good
um now it's never too late to mess up
queen c2 would run into bishop h8 and it
will get murky
might even be just lost
so some precision is still required from
jeffrey
to actually clench it
maybe something like queen d6
threatening rook d1
maybe queen d6 then e5
but queen d6 e5 something like queen d4
and queen h4 is on the button
if you take i just check meet you with
my queen
so what black really wants to set up is
rook d1 exchange everything and then
there's the
background mate
yep queen d6 e5 and
queen d4 if they take then queen h4
take a check checkmate if you take i'll
just take and i'm up
the exchange and apart from being up the
exchange rook d
one is winning so there might be
one last tricks meanwhile
lenny did agree to a draw
so officially the match has been won
by the archbishops so
that means that's eight and a half four
there's no way of catching
meanwhile wesley also one so it's nine
and a half right now
and this will be the 10th
game point for the
archbishops
we're getting there we're getting there
we're waiting for the 10th and
that'll be a clincher e6 still trying
still trying
but just a simple well simple takes
yeah it takes is good because if you
take
take the queen from the dead will still
come back
to haunt lee chao and that'll be good
enough
for the win
yep takes jeffrey is
precise to the max and jeffrey pushes
the score
up to the tenths so
10 and a half four and we still have one
last game
pending between fabiano corona
and dingler and but already the rgb
bishops
have won the match so this
is the last game still pending
the result won't change however if we
still care
there'll be some issues on the second
rank
so fabi does have to be careful not to
lose
this one
and that will mean that the saying those
arch bishops
are going to be slated for the final
the final and if you want to know who
they're facing
that's going to be in a different match
in an hour
okay rook b2 but after knight d4
this is more or less even
there's not much play left
for ding he has a slight bit of an
advantage because this rook is strong
enough
and this rook is passive but objectively
it shouldn't be more
than a draw
h4
king g6 just trying to bring the king up
the board
rook d3
king h5 trying to win the pawn
or key 3 and just activating the rook
and once fabi gets the d5 pawn
it's a draw
key five possibly rook b5 will be
forced defending that square
but then this king is a little bit off
sides like pieces do look
too passive to actually
do any damage to fabi's position
in fact rook b would be five bishop f3
is a neat little
mating pattern that you rarely see
yep and after bishop f3
it's either you go bishop g4 and which
peter is into
a draw or you don't play bishop g4 but
in that case you get
mated i mean bishop d5
is also good enough both cases
leading to a draw the ship takes f takes
in g5 and
the match ends with fabi drawing with
ding liran
and st louis wins with 11
to 5 solid performance
by fabiano and the team
they won when it mattered
with the first round that was a little
bit dodgy
and was back and forth on the second
and third rounds they clinched it
second round that 2-0 is very important
just to get in the groove of the match
but this means that st louis goes
on to the final talking about the final
if you are interested to know what
you're going to see
you should check out the chess bras
versus the armenian eagles
match that's going to happen in an hour
and then you'll find out who the saint
louis archbishops is going to
face in the finals that will be
happening
on sunday september 27th
probably around the same time as today
so with that and thank you for
watching and see you on sunday
so
you